Celt you want to do this together okay
together I'm on a morning show I've
never felt more seen in my life oh
really
oh my god there's some of those
monologues and I'm like you speak to me
and all my friends and family I really
liked that and I was like no it's way
better
oh no well hey as long as we're
representing in the most correct way
that's all that's way you did us justice
jennifer aniston very happy news we are
so glad you're back at the party here
tonight when your friend when your peers
and your friends and your co-workers say
Jennifer well done I shop what is that
like it's probably one of the greater
nights of these of this you know so
called season because it is our peers so
it's very bit special how far along are
we for season two now where we add
people here we go more tabloid fodder
alone how far along are we these into
like what are we working out we are well
it is like a baby let's face it it is
like birth we're we're getting there we
read one and two and it's pretty good
and it's gonna be it's really I'm under
playing it as you can tell by the grin
on my face I know that you're a big
bachelor fan have you been able to catch
up on pilot Pete yet of course okay what
do you think of his season who's a
front-runner champagne gate oh man you
know I may hold that prediction for one
more one Marshall I do think she's done
wait.you but I think she might you don't
think yes he has so many unresolved
feelings for that go for sure yeah but
that should have another just using
these poor women as like now it's you
know at the same yeah at their sake it's
not you love it I know you look like a
dream Jen what do you manage what do you
make of all the ridiculous is about you
and
bread reuniting on all these carpets all
season long it's hysterical but what
else are they going to talk about I'd
like to talk about your dress yes I
would like to talk about that this is
John Galliano for Christian Dior this is
a vintage dress that I have in my
present that I gave to myself you just
pulled this out of the Jennifer closet
just yeah
wait a minute ho hold the phone come
over for the Oscars well this is an
investment these are designers that
aren't working for those [ __ ] you
know it's just sort of you know we have
the same birthday I could borrow
birthday twins yeah February 11 oh yeah
birthday twins we just entered into the
Age of Aquarius did it's gonna be a good
seriously this is our year it's this
2020 is this is our year you heard it
here
[Music]